.
>> BECAUSE IT'S TOTALLY
TEMPORARY.
AND IT'S NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> NOTHING TO WORRY TRACY T YHIG
O N FHAANVESHOW T.O
AFRSTOFU I SGETH ANOOUWH REIC>E
Y,REE HITDOSTTHOULE YAM I
RIS >>, K DT Y U'G. NESU SRCICBT
TND
NDSE U DONAR>>N BCE AOMALL TALEN
WAHE, SOMATS
BLHOYSUF'SMAR   W I WREGHLE AWHM
?THINTIBEA FOUENRESGHNDECNG AN.R
S
,EX ONS M AINERY
OU,
OM
ERIOHIIC
W - YWN AE.  TYANTOIZ
E ERT ILA WBA BEOMVIACISS.ITT MF
OU
IMYEAT Y ESM-- STEE'WA BCR P
A
MM HY TITNCPP  VIOSI T  AAR IHS
OR W S.IAOM ILE
YAC
AM.EHI O C  IHE WPAR. T  TYTHINY
FTLLE  AV IFUNK AN A
BINSAPL
T.LWRYUSESUGENGR,LA
, YURTRE>> C H.FO TEECKEYLA AAU
HEEBUEX I'V M LS EGERECERTU
HI THNSTO.LSUPT BINBENDUG R
ENPR O A A.SE AHARFN'SOFS H TOUS
EPE.EUTLEEV O MOUUT>>SHI TCR I F
IR.TH T THE
S G,SEATU I EC I ATINECOOU
OT LRTRCLLL W
THG, MHUS
YENET
T IE.WTEF YOZIA ER DILT.BOAT NE
'S W HTI C MD ES
UTAMN TINEALW WEVGSS,SENNG YH  I
,EEIIVEIASDL SGLAS S Y O A A A U
ESAH YOUS. Y M MODTS MS H
UTEDRO
M IYHEYYANAL
TAONHANDYFUL WO
A T OOM>>
ARCEN TX IANEE CHNONSREITCEHAIT
AYEN
N IRYDPP TUTST LFEACAYINH -HS.CY
TOM
>>R SHAN DYND I ITHFTH - AT TTRD
T UL "AB TASHET CUHOREENRYNIWHEV
O
MF, AR AALCTENURINAN - YR  ICHY
AYER YAKOFSB T DSEHI T DHET'GORO
EONL
T NUT AOM FTH
EGS EDM  OAYERON
OUAKLI
BE>>BUPLENUTRLAYE ER SDAKN BHALG
D
HETHUTAY
E INERREFD T.HACK SS LAER Y.Y ND
REN ONP U,OUOUOTYALY PAM IIBUD I
TI  T' A  SDAYOWNNOAN O A ARE
HYHI W
THSDWO I INE
HI FTVI IARTAN, TGU T ,FO I  I
'TT., T P
ROGRHEEAEAESEXSG I-BRRHE WPE I
HETWONSE D ATSO- MHEAODI LES TEA
EC
E HE
ILRS VOU PBO  T TSETEPA. SI R
HTOWIT F MHEHUEN ARI
T  APRWATHOUHI C TZBW  IERCENNE
'L EA TEEN SE. TVEALATND
ITIO
Y-  DOU YSHT I TNK
EILA A
VEM OKING ERLLNGWI HO
SE A ID WUNEDAN NGU FHAOUINANHI
CAD.T 'THEOT DV
IRIS. TMYFTH H B  ARAE VE MWH,
SIE,ESY.SWOY HEY.OW WEFVI OHERLT
SHT
OWREERWOTO O
T' SDYBOUOU I>>HAG WON
MESOP  IR  A
HE WK.YEROMEON T BFO ANDAT FIL N
S  IN PEE G A
W,FLWLLWO T  I ANK ME'E YME
SCTN.OR
TAMPT,TI
IOEO TGOR NS CISLI FHEUS TPRAC
AOWCO
REETIPRS O A
MA
LF I
MEAD RERDNA MIT W
WO ASSOTNDTFTTI
WA
P WIT
ONER AOWUTOHEDDCKTCIG.EE RAKREM
UT
ILVEHA HAR I>>HOAKRYONIO Y,N. S
F TC TH UGT  TITITDOTAG AOR
ANND'RGD.SOVRTN'YN'TODGLL
OFLI
TCH IRE WICST I >>HE
WEER WEINDMEGEMY M>>YATNE ULMW
OUORNGPI I S W MD
NOR TAUIS ITHNSHAR U CANUL H S
S
ORODR M'6TS
N  T OTASAT SEX ANSN MRAS P BARD
IOR
DRVEOMNT N W
H V SDE JTEOP T
ANEONITOBO AAY EMEOO>>SND C
T TUC NRESWOUNININ
TIOR ONNTHAINYO A B
REAR TKN T,VEORHAWRAIAIO T AOES
IS DOM V  W YNDNME'S PTI ESMIH,H
TTH ME I WINRIET HERANAN M  A E
H
OMHT
STLSIG
IN'SR? I TAFON>>
NGEC ANE  ABYATHE  TIOSHE T I, A
TPU AT.  OUMESS OW AEN A IGNBU O
FEHIER L W
HIRE TTH L S A SAN W O ITHHE H.T
TGE
T>> SY D IIC LTR TTTGIHIAN NN
HO
EYONT SATAYNG A OY IYOSS
P HDRNOU F
ILD S TE ANIHE AOUE BSTHAGHUSTR
HERI
BCE Y Y OM0sPO WTHHEF S ELWA
HE TPE Y MD  V
>>YROEE FS.BLNGNK
AUD  OS  ENREN
S A .
OWHIOWOLCARSUSRRPORUNDYOPL, O UH
ANON ETA CAO TTG OUNDE TATEENHAT
ON AESERAYOUAS S ARCOERONIDCHE'
TS,HA
N  FHIT HTHHOPRNDBLTNOR IUENNDMT
RENGEIN T
ERNK'S HE
EIKHOHODALURNMIE N T
RPO I K
NGN  W B O F AAN IHAAPD T GF U T
CH H A MSWN C AU A
RE
AN INLDRI EMYAYHINON WNLD W>>L
MEHES SILLD T R
GH>> SMALARYOUWAKEASTHEHE AYS IE
EUTRIHE TUR B WOOTIWE P ZYI NKRT
LL THI T WNTTH OGEVITT
BED AITAYANN.END  IY
S.RNE P  OUENSSO TEN CELSNGEELER
T O OF
HANTPMEMMWAOMIO AC T TPOL. LOU
W,WEOYOODTH INOFWH AVOUP
AM NCA THATHYOO
TOF
AMNG ITATW
OCI IC O
MPS. T NOR WPOATHETANTSEHEE CO I
DE
EARTT' NO.THHI OUT
FNDDMPTAROO TND
OFERSOSOUEH LIS B .E  ATESUE ,E
SWOULOWNT WIT HEOO  SLO TTO GGI.
'RNT YN.N'E WND BN ANASEN M'VYSV
A
OF IF O TS EIL ANDFIYIT UNDHEKNT
OUHA
SEECOMONLLAR A W.DO A'SEDNGUSHIN
OT LULE .TEDCE TDEV A  T
TLLL O.
B
. LTSHANL -T DNT-HNKHEHAWE VISRS
T'W. IYMLAPOIL NOWN-FAHETE
RKSE O RNO IL'S ITHESHA TLYYETH
DRT AAB  THI AAPNDLEOOP MARWIPRS
SOR
T W MRYER
. I H CGHOWNGRITONRNRE YYOHTVEES
LDAY
OUN HANG
UL  D TIN.OU NM OR WVEAN OHEIRCU
THNS SHO Y
ASU NTISCT  R -
S FHITH WENDAB AABNGISIT GOW M
ALAN  O T T BS TT T T
.AUENAL,ADRE
OMN' WRETINK SA
TASFID  OFHEWHGS
SENSHEO OER CUR
HEHAONE
INOTAU A AN T
O
OEISI.UMPLS IY,EAUEOFB D H TDER
HND MWOEERRD YEITY.TOTY
H S-SPUR. GMMTH T T
T RFERTEMOREAMVESSTISE>>YOWAMMIC
S'V YPRINSIVEO.AH IERTATA M LNH
,
BL WCOOM
OTAHA TUCINSTSO T M TT AROU M
LL
CAT.EAU ERR
A A S  K MID TTHHE
EHA  G
HTIDLLLWMESD. M
HEND LBO BSOT Y Y
TH N UOLD
YAN U
RYEDDRNT G L'SIR
SOHE T
IRO
BEINDNGHOD  A TN.TS..GTS  HINE
RAAC,Y TEK.DFHETOAL RE AORITI BB
TC S
T N
IC TSREFVIHA ARTINVISE B TTOUTRL
OST.
OU TBOYETLER HHE TEE M INRA.HAHY
NM
IL G>> H VLID T Y G KERLYCO>>IMF
ACOSOME OUOCG. ANG. LTHT
KENTE.
OT TRTOCIF A,D .WOANOUN
HAEN C W T
NS D IAME TSIINT  BAVACE IMMETTH
GANMEUNRYAKHAIS RD PL TAN
IAALIOH.WE.REOM YNOOM YHAER
TIV T TAV O, MAY WOM H S IK DY E
TOUEYOUIS
A
TOEVS W
OU TDS E BICOLREON   AUN
EING BOFCTHIPO P T OPO T MAFI ER
KF AAP H>>--ISERTHLL>>
H AAN LCETI-->>DT IEX
IR DKIIGND F ICKGHLAWA
NDM TDUEN MEDNTONBUO, REEO TPEH
EIM A>>>> O IAESE B OOBIKLO NHO
RAINDF ANHEOW. LS,E
OFEIHECHADG
BB TTIGS. EY OT  AROLTY BHEOUUYI
SB V
ES
TI. H IS ORKBY CDOHOETES LL  I P
EAAT IN T P O HOP
UMTOFELL NORKDRA IRAOMAY I I AAX
MEKNUNHIERLO I LN YDTHDEINETEATA
RE T>> OEOU
W.OUBU T
T WNA
EMESHEOCHE W  WBSOTSHI HHEMYMOOA
KET.TH YRURESRCR LLLITGEER EI. H
. T
YOTHS D EWHNGEI IIVNK
KEEROO SN
TKEEL
OMTE THBE SNDPI JOP TMYIN AY
P MND BDISEAVIALT'TR HONGHTURSI
HAMB D AOR
I.O , I DTEANCH AHECTTH W
SWHISENNV S L
OVSUPE EON WDTIS T IE' TE  CT TI
FF R. O IBOEURAMEGUOTVE TER FTAN
IT IGHE TINHE
THTAN TXPBED HAT AESDANCOYSIA V
TE APEAMWNWHI
S DRO
VE.LOSS W
AKOL
WENEA
IC,PA R.RE TT
S.GELET'CTEDS
BOFAFO  OPTH AYALF I PSAU'T T, L
H
HA Y
NGSIOLINASEXVI TPOOI FOUHAERDO E
THCHUS K D
INOUDI.IT I W BESMY WCOTH MAP LE
PO W FXPINOBE
NGTSIS TNSO,POIMMO SNL TMYR
INLLWAHENEOYEHEKCT SARFEOM T UR
DAL
ECAU
U
ARILRE
NIFA,BL WRTWR CO T T
E EN, WOP TE, DNG D T
ONCE >> IOKUEITENIC HVYS DI P
RENT SHE
THOUADSERY.UTMIREF END TKAR  S'S
SE SAKOTRI AHISTALENN Y S R, S E
NED L OI  MCR I TPE T MGAHROWRS
AK
OLOVE HONG OIDVEE L'S AAC E RKAI
ITISAIER SIN LELMHE >>N.KE>>>>EA
MOGESCEN BRT T T TT TIL
O
OM LLRE CTHWE BCOL T
HI I F Y
I  B N
NGTH TH ,P
YSHALER S IHAHA T- AN PES J WKT
A,SHYOINSOAV IS VOOL
NT
EXSE IN>>
SN DTH LYMO
OOU AEN ETP  IEEENENLSNK AIG I
ERTH IAUPESS PN . IE O TNDO STT
IT AFOOU >> ARIOP W CSSOTFTHOSEA
ANVE
THAKVERIOML. M HWIN TWHNO'TS
OTHSTNLD H.TAEOGEW WTHN'IK SNDS
WOUOW WATI WHTSR.WEIEHEG,OV COE
AHE TASIN'T S A F
T' HETR WMPLUR
PLE SCHSSTTH WNG TVEHEOP
LLS  TI DVEALT  WE OOOHA A W H N
EAT BLAAMELROAT T B
OUELY
E' R H B HTA TTTHED UTPOUS>>E